merci d'être avec toi Elisabeth Bonneau
et de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure vous êtes sénatrice
centriste de la Mayenne rapporteur
général du budget de la Sécurité sociale
dont l'examen a lieu cette semaine ça a
commencé hier on va bien sûr longuement
parler dans quelques minutes mais
d'abord un mot sur une question question
pouvoir d'achat qui préoccupe les
Français notamment la question des
cantines scolaires puisque les
entreprises de la restauration
collective réclament une nouvelle hausse
de leur contrat s'ils n'ont ils
demandent à pouvoir ombre ces contrats
ils disent qu'il faut en passer par là
pour continuer à pouvoir fournir des
repas locaux des repas bio est-ce que ça
vous semble tenable pour les familles et
pour les Mairies que doivent-elles faire
et je crois qu'en fait cette
difficulté elle est autant chez les
collectivités que chez les fournisseurs
et en fait elle devrait forcément
venir aux familles c'est compliqué parce
que
souvenez-vous au mois de juillet nous
avons voté un projet de loi de
financement rectificatif nous avons pris
en compte les difficultés
collectivité qu'elle soit commune ou
intercommunalité pour venir auprès
justement de ces collectivités qui
étaient en fragilité budgétaire et
justement pallier aux difficultés
qu'elles pourraient rencontrer au niveau
de la fourniture alimentaire mais aussi
fournitures d'énergie et donc je pense
que ça ne doit pas se régler dans les
médias parce que là on voit bien que
finalement les choses ne se font pas
entre responsables des collectivités et
responsables justement les fournisseurs
de repas et et ça se règle un peu dans
les médias je pense que il faut
aujourd'hui être devant finalement cette
difficulté qui est commune qui est
collective chacun aujourd'hui doit
prendre sa part et donc ils font en
discuter et je pense que d'ailleurs la
circulaire de la première ministre qui a
été validé par le Conseil d'État permet
justement de renégocier ces contrats
parce que c'était pas forcément le cas
il y a quelques temps donc ça veut dire
que tout le monde doit prendre sa part
collectivité fournisseurs évidemment et
aussi les familles est-ce qu'il faut
qu'elles acceptent de payer un petit peu
plus cher le prix des repas mais je
pense qu'il faut accepter de payer un
peu plus cher mais surtout tenir compte
aussi de la capacité des familles et
donc il faut peut-être regarder ça avec
le quotient familial ou en tout cas
faire plus comme on dirait de l'État
en fait on peut pas tout demander à
l'État c'est pour ça qu'il faut partager
entre les collectivités l'État et les
familles mais il faut aussi être plus
solidaire vis-à-vis des familles les
plus en difficulté on va parler du
budget de la Sécu puisque l'examen a
débuté hier après-midi dans l'hémicycle
on va voir les temps forts de cette
première séance avec Alex pousseur
[Musique]
bonjour Elisabeth Bonneau
du budget de la Sécurité sociale en
pleine crise de l'hôpital mais oui c'est
le début de l'examen du PLFSS le projet
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale un budget qui passe pour la
première fois le seuil symbolique des
600 milliards d'euros avec le déficit le
fameux trou de la Sécu qu'il va s'élever
pour les prochaines à 7 milliards
d'euros il est en diminution par rapport
à la période covid le budget de
l'hôpital lui augmente de 4% c'est à
dire à peine l'inflation alors que de
nombreux services sont sous tension on
va écouter le ministre de la Santé
François Brunin
ce PLFSS a aussi pour ambition de
renforcer notre hôpital avec des moyens
et une reconnaissance à la hauteur du
service qui rend aux Français trop
longtemps nous soignons dû mettre les
bouchées doubles pour compenser des
décennies d'économies réalisées sur
l'hôpital au prix d'un désespoir
grandissant chez certains de nos
professionnels
ce sont ces choix passés et répétés qui
font que nous avons aujourd'hui à gérer
des urgences successives alors face à
ces urgences notamment pour les services
de pédiatrie François Brune annonce
quasiment chaque semaine une enveloppe
supplémentaire pour l'hôpital 150
millions d'euros puis 400 millions
d'euros ce sera au final 600 millions
d'euros supplémentaires une enveloppe
qui a été votée hier par les sénateurs
même si selon eux elle arrive à la
dernière minute ils sont à peu près au
dépourvu et puis elle n'est pas vraiment
financée elle serait même financée en
puisant dans les propres fonds de
l'hôpital autour de passe-passe
budgétaire qui énerve la droite
sénatoriale écoutez René Paul Savary
dans un délai aussi réduit on est mis
devant le fait accompli et vous faites
des annonces aux Hospitaliers monsieur
le mini j'en suis désolé sur le dos des
Hospitaliers donc ça ça devient quand
même
particulièrement difficile me
semble-t-il et à l'ex du côté de la
gauche du Sénat certains groupes ne
souhaitent même pas examiner ce budget
oui pour les créateurs de gauche ce
budget de la Sécurité sociale n'est pas
assez ambitieux il ne va faire que
prolonger la crise de notre système de
santé alors les sénateurs communistes
ont déposé au début de l'examen une
émotion de rejet du texte écouter la
sénatrice communiste Laurence Cohen
en persévérant dans vos choix en
amplifiant la logique qui est la vôtre
qui considère la santé comme un coup
qu'il faut réduire vous détruisez la
sécurité sociale à laquelle les
Françaises et les Français sont
tellement attachés et vous précipitez
les départs des Hospitaliers alors au
final cette motion de rejet n'a pas été
adoptée par le Sénat sur les communistes
et les écologistes ont voté mais du côté
des socialistes on s'est quand même posé
la question de l'intérêt de ce débat sur
le budget de la Sécurité sociale
puisqu'ensuite le texte reviendra à
l'Assemblée nationale et le gouvernement
utilisera l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution pour l'adopter sans vote en
tout cas on va écouter sur ce point
d'ailleurs Bernard jaumier le sénateur
socialiste le 49-3 bah rend incertain
nos délibérations par essence puisqu'on
sait que quand il repartira l'Assemblée
nationale il sera l'objet d'un nouveau
49-3 donc on ne sait pas trop s'il est
très utile de mener certains débats
voilà un peu d'incertitude en tout cas
le débat sur ce budget de la Sécu est
bien lancé au Sénat avec une première
modification
voter hier soir le Sénat s'est opposé au
transfert du recouvrement des
cotisations retraite de la caisse agic
Carco agicarco vers la sécurité sociale
vers l'URSSAF ça concerne et bien les
retraites complémentaires c'est une
réforme un peu technique souhaitée par
le gouvernement et donc qui est déjà
refusé par le Sénat sud des débats cet
après-midi et Isabelle Doisneau ce
budget augmente les dépenses d'assurance
maladie il réduit le défi de le déficit
de la Sécurité sociale qu'est-ce qui ne
va pas dans ce budget qu'est ce qui est
insuffisant alors je voudrais tout
d'abord dire que moi je me suis opposé à
cette motion pourquoi parce que le
budget de la Sécurité sociale il faut
que chacun soit aussi en conscience
averti c'est 5 fois le budget de la
défense quatre fois celui de l'éducation
donc ne pas en discuter c'est voilà
renverser d'un revers de main si je puis
dire un débat qui a son importance pour
la vie au quotidien des français même si
vous vous faites pas d'illusion
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être repris par
le gouvernement au final qui va utiliser
le 49-3 pour qu'il y ait une discussion
entre Sénat et le gouvernement mais déjà
ce qui était important c'est qu'on
rétablisse les parties 1 et 2 qui avait
été en fait voilà retiré du texte par
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est deux
parties on leur importance puisqu'on est
sur l'exemple oui ça concerne les
comptes l'exercice Claude 2021 et aussi
l'année en cours avec les objectifs de
recettes et puis les prévisions de
dépenses mais juste pour poursuivre la
question d'Alex avant de rentrer dans le
détail avec lui puisque vous avez
regretté un débat tronqué à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que là vous avez la
garantie d'un vrai débat et pour vous
reposer la question est-ce que vous avez
des garanties que le gouvernement
reprendra des mesures votées par le
Sénat après passage du 49-3 où est-ce
que vous avez un peu l'impression que ça
sera un débat pour rien alors non on n'a
pas le sentiment ce sera un débat pour
rien parce que déjà on échange sur un
ensemble de problématiques c'est vrai
qu'on n'a jamais autant dépensé d'argent
pour la santé des français mais aussi
pour l'ensemble des branches parce que
je vous rappelle la branche autonomie
finalement elle est là que depuis
quelques années donc on n'a jamais
autant dépensé et pour autant le
paradoxe c'est que finalement il y a
beaucoup de et d'incompréhension et
aussi de colère par rapport au système
notamment sur l'accès aux soins on voit
bien que les territoires sont en tension
parce que la population n'a pas
forcément en tout cas une réponse et un
médecin traitant pour le dire court et
puis il y a aussi toute cette difficulté
qui est rencontrée à l'hôpital notamment
on l'a vu dans les services de pédiatrie
mais dans les services des urgences cet
été et à chaque fois effectivement
l'état arrive un peu en pompier si je
puis dire et fait du coup par coup nous
ce que nous avons voulu savoir hier soir
c'est comment justement était répartis
ces millions annoncés parce que on est
là sur des montants qui sont quand même
très très importants et la sincérité du
budget elle réside aussi dans
l'explication de texte et dans la
répartition des enveloppes budgétaires
cette enveloppe supplémentaire de 600
millions d'euros pour soutenir l'hôpital
annoncé par François Braun elle est
suffisante selon vous alors certainement
pas parce que je pense que en fait la
réponse financière n'est pas toujours la
seule réponse à apporter on voit bien
que après la crise du covid l'ensemble
des services des hôpitaux mais aussi
tous les soignants tous ceux qui
apportent aussi du soin et de
l'accompagnement aux personnes en
difficulté et bien il y a eu vraiment
comment un ras-le-bol une perte de sens
et il y a vraiment eu le sentiment
d'avoir été trop compressé broyer par le
système je pense que toutes ces
professionnels on fait des efforts
considérables mais il est pas évident de
se sortir d'une crise comme celle-ci il
y a eu des professionnels qui ont quitté
milieu de l'hôpital beaucoup de
d'infirmières d'aide soignants et
aujourd'hui rouvrir des lits c'est c'est
peut-être un vœu pieux parce qu'il faut
les trouver
professionnel partout on a des
difficultés pour trouver et des médecins
et aujourd'hui des infirmières et des
aides soignants et d'autres
professionnels de santé d'ailleurs
moi je pense qu'il faut
les ministres parlent de réenchanter les
métiers du soin et du prendre du prendre
soin oui sans doute mais le chemin va
être long le chemin va être long je
pense que il faut aussi penser à la
gouvernance de nos hôpitaux c'est
important aussi de savoir que les
services sont portés par une dynamique
par une vraie volonté d'organisation et
ça passe finalement par beaucoup de
mesures beaucoup d'outils qui ne sont
pas forcément dans une enveloppe
budgétaire donc pour vous il ne faut pas
allonger l'enveloppe budgétaire du
gouvernement c'est aussi des questions
d'organisation pour retrouver du sens à
ces métiers mais je pense qu'en fait
c'est pas le seul levier il faudra
peut-être encore l'augmenter mais ce
n'est pas le seul levier je pense qu'il
ne suffit pas de distribuer pour
finalement assainir des difficultés qui
ne sont pas que d'ordre budgétaire
la stratégie qui est mise en place par
l'actuel ministre de la Santé François
Beaune qui est aux manettes depuis
quelques mois pour sauver l'hôpital mais
écoutez je pense que
[Musique]
animations on sait très bien et on l'a
dit pendant la crise covid que là encore
il y a des besoins donc répondre en
termes financier c'est une chose mais
aussi il faut y répondre sur un temps
long avec la formation des
professionnels et puis aussi je dirais
l'organisation de notre système alors ce
débat sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale va permettre d'ouvrir les
discussions sur la réforme des retraites
puisque dans ce texte la majorité de
droite et du sang de sénatorial propose
sa propre réforme des retraites avec en
cas d'échec de négociation entre les
partenaires sociaux la proposition d'un
recul de l'âge de départ à 64 ans
Isabelle Doisneau qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est la réforme d'Emmanuel Macron avant
l'heure ben écoutez nous en tout cas on
est constant ça fait depuis 2019 que
René Paul Savary présente le même
amendement il serait certainement mieux
en parler que moi je pense que en
réalité si le gouvernement a reporté
cette réforme c'est qu'il n'a pas su
sans doute mettre autour de la table
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux parce
que c'était là aussi
l'objet d'une réforme ne se fait pas
on a décrétant il faut aussi réunir
finalement toutes les personnes qui
peuvent y participer notamment pour
représenter l'ensemble des des
entreprises que ce soit sur
la branche je dirais pas trop mal que
sur la branche salariale donc nous ce
qu'on dit depuis invariablement depuis
ces dernières années c'est qu'il faut
réunir tous ces partenaires sociaux
qu'il faut laisser la place au dialogue
social et on fait confiance en fait à
nos partenaires sociaux et on donne un
an en réalité la dernière c'était une
conférence aujourd'hui on a même
rebaptisé ça en une convention nationale
pour le maintien des seniors dans
l'emploi et aussi le maintien de notre
réforme de notre système de retraite
donc une proposition avant leur nom je
pense qu'on est constant en fait on dit
les choses je crois qu'on veut pas faire
peser sur les générations futures
finalement des non décisions on
procrastine en permanence en France en
se disant oui ce sera pour demain mais
la réalité c'est que quand on regarde le
déficit de la branche vieillesse dès
2026 il est quand même à -16 milliards
d'euros et les propositions que l'on
fait avec un âge de report à 64 ans de
l'âge de la retraite et aussi
l'accélération des mesures Touraine donc
le temps de cotisation
pour avoir
c'est la durée de cotisation et bien ça
ça prend en partie ce déficit mais on
voit bien qu'il y a vraiment aujourd'hui
à prendre en compte mais c'est plutôt le
chemin sur lequel se dirige le
gouvernement et des consultations sont
en cours du coup pourquoi le remettre
dans le PLFSS c'est un message politique
mais je pense que vous avez raison on a
été sans doute inspirant pour le
gouvernement maintenant
c'est sûr que
on nous a toujours dit que ça ne pouvait
pas se faire au travers d'un amendement
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
contact pour vous ou ça aurait pu passer
par un agent vrai texte oui c'est sans
doute mieux mais je pense que nous avons
été inspirants et en tout cas
nous avons été finalement assez
classique dans nos propositions nous
avons pas nous n'avons pas
inventé chaque année de nouvelles
dispositions en fait voilà on a été
constant on va continuer à parler de ce
texte de la question des déserts
médicaux merci beaucoup Alex merci
d'avoir été avec nous à tout à l'heure
on va parler des réfugiés Ukrainiens
dans le club avec vous tout au sujet on
continue sur ce texte on va aller chez
vous à Laval en Mayenne retrouvée
Guillaume Bougnol bonjour directeur
départemental de Ouest-France en Mayenne
la Mayenne deuxième désert médical de
français c'est évidemment un sujet que
vous traitez régulièrement dans vos
pages
[Musique]
oui alors bonjour Monsieur le Directeur
j'ai toujours salué l'investissement de
mes collègues parlementaires sur cette
question parce que effectivement on
répond à une problématique qui est
vraiment installé malheureusement depuis
quelques années et le département de la
Mayenne est effectivement en difficulté
par rapport à la présence de médecins
sur l'ensemble du territoire cependant
il y a déjà plus d'une dizaine d'années
nous avions au niveau du département
alerté sur cette difficulté et surtout
nous avions pris des mesures des mesures
incitatives des mesures pour aider
l'installation et accompagner les jeunes
professionnels donc un certain nombre de
dispositifs que vous connaissez qui ont
été d'ailleurs
accélérés et comment dirais-je
multiplier dans les états généraux de la
santé que qui ont été organisés par le
département de la Mayenne vous les
connaissez ces dispositifs et bien nous
nous avions mis en place aujourd'hui
appeler
comment les dispositifs que proposent
mes collègues c'est je pense difficile
parce que on peut pas gérer
les partage je dirais des médecins par
la coercition en réalité on ne peut pas
distribuer ce qu'on a pas comment
c'est prendre chez Paul pour coiffer
pierre en fait je ne vois pas comment la
coercition pour amener une solution
positive moi je crois plutôt à la
citation à l'accompagnement c'est ce
qu'on fait depuis un certain nombre
d'années je voudrais rappeler quand même
que l'année dernière c'était la première
année où nous avions plus de médecins
s'installer que de médecins à partir bon
c'est une dynamique effectivement qu'il
faut encore encourager je ne pense pas
que la coercition quand on fait des
études de médecine qui dure 9 ans et là
vous l'avez vu avec le projet de de
comment de loi de financement la
sécurité sociale il y a l'allongement à
10 ans mais ça a été aussi porté par une
proposition de loi de Bruno Retailleau
on porte à 10 ans les études pendant 10
ans
pour vous moi je pense que la
professionnalisation elle était sans
doute à revoir mais cependant
allongé les études de médecine c'est
encore reporté l'arrivée de jeunes
médecins sur les territoires même si on
nous dit que ce ne sera pas une année
blanche et bien moi j'en doute
vous êtes incité mais pas forcé donc en
réalité ils pourront aussi passer leur
temps de cette dernière année peut-être
à l'hôpital où on a aussi besoin d'un
terme moi je dis que l'hôpital si on
enlevait tous les internes ne
fonctionnerait pas il faut aussi le dire
donc on a besoin des jeunes
professionnels aussi bien l'hôpital que
sur les terrains je dirais
sur les territoires plutôt mais le la
coercition ne semble pas être la bonne
solution on ne part pas ce qu'on n'a pas
regardé aujourd'hui on nous compare
souvent enfin on compare ces
dispositions au fait que les professeurs
voilà sont affectés dans des territoires
plus difficiles bon d'accord mais
jusqu'à il y a quelques temps on avait
assez de professeurs mais aujourd'hui
c'est pas le cas est-ce que pour autant
l'obligation d'installation ou d'exercer
à finalement générer le fait que on est
des professionnels partout non donc et
les pharmaciens c'est encore autre chose
les infirmières autre chose on ne gère
on ne gère pas la pénurie par la
coercition c'est une question évidemment
d'inquiétude pour les Français mais une
question politique à l'Assemblée
d'ailleurs il y a eu débat au sein même
de la majorité entre le groupe horizon
et le comprenaissance puisqu’orizon
était pour des mesures plus coercitives
ils disent que les déserts médicaux
c'est un carburant pour le rassemblement
national vous êtes d'accord avec ça ben
écoutez je dois dire que je suis assez
d'accord j'ai eu l'opportunité d'aller
en Suède avec la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
Catherine de roche
nous en France 10 à 12% de nos
concitoyens n'ont pas de médecin
traitants là-bas en Suède c'est que 30%
de la population qui a un médecin
traitant donc vous imaginez ils
reconnaissent qu'ils n'ont pas pris
suffisamment en compte le vieillissement
de la population et l'arrivée de
situations complexe des personnes qui
ont des multiples pathologies et qui
prennent du temps médical et
effectivement cette anticipation n'a pas
été faite en Suède aujourd'hui on voit
le résultat en termes de vote et
l'arrivée de l'extrême droite donc je
suis d'accord il faut qu'on soit plus
pédagogue il faut aussi qu'on explique
aux Français avec courage et et je pense
sans se cacher que les choses vont être
encore difficiles c'est un problème de
démographie de la population des
professionnels de santé et de la
population en elle-même mettre en
addictquation ce vieillissement de la
population ce besoin en termes de temps
de santé il faut le dire aux Français
c'est quelque chose qui ne se décrète
pas et qui en fait ne organise pas du
jour au lendemain on va retourner chez
vous en Mayenne à l'aval on retrouve
Guillaume parler d'un autre sujet
puisque Emmanuel Macron qui est de
retour de la cop27 reçois aujourd'hui à
l'Élysée les 50 industrielle les plus
polluants de France et parmi eux sont en
magnésium
[Musique]
alors écoutez
ce sujet concerne deux entreprises mais
attention si ce sont des grosses
entreprises là on est sur deux sites
vous parlez de Lafarge et de l'Ouest
Lafarge voilà c'est 150 salariés en
Mayenne mais à travers le monde c'est
des milliers de salariés et c'est pareil
pour le groupe Holcim je voudrais dire
que c'est important en termes aussi de
propositions d'emplois sur le territoire
quand vous regardez précisément ces deux
entreprises que je connais l'une et
l'autre elles ont déjà posé des jalons
pour être finalement
plus vertueuse dans le domaine de
l'empreinte
écologique et donc elles font des
efforts donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on les met un peu au bon désacusés je
voudrais tout de même dire que d'abord
c'est de l'emploi sur un territoire et
qu'ensuite et ça je propose à chacun
d'aller sur les sites des deux groupes
en particulier vous voyez qu'ils ont
déjà posé déjà pour réduire les taux de
gaz à effet de serre et de réduire aussi
la production de de CO2 donc il faut
aussi
marquer marquer les efforts qui sont
faits ils ont des objectifs ils ont une
stratégie je pense que la question ce
n'est pas tant
est-ce qu'il faut que l'État les aides
je pense que la question c'est est-ce
qu'il faut qu'il reste en France c'est
ça la question et donc nous nous disons
oui il faut rester en France il faut
leur donner les moyens de rester en
France et leur donner les moyens d'avoir
un un calendrier un agenda je dirais
pour répondre à cette problématique et
qui est effectivement une problématique
dont ils ont pris conscience et sur
laquelle nous nous sommes aussi très
conscients des efforts qu'il faut faire
donc l'état aujourd'hui leur propose
sans doute aux uns et aux autres de
prendre aussi
des commandes des exemples parce que
la difficulté c'est aussi de trouver les
les outils pour améliorer les choses et
on peut s'inspirer aussi des pratiques
d'autres entreprises et je crois que le
fait de les réunir c'est peut-être aussi
trouver cette dynamique collective et de
trouver les moyens voilà de s'améliorer
merci d'avoir été avec nous la Une de
Ouest-France mitterme aux États-Unis le
vote décisif des minorités c'est à la
Une de votre journal et merci Elisabeth
Dano d'avoir été avec nous pendant cette
première demi-heure l'examen du budget
de la Sécurité sociale se poursuit cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle on suivra
bien surtout ça
[Musique]